[Music]
Aleksey Rosenfeld has dived all over the
world this is something new
along with his team he's diving where no
human has been before we're now 135
kilometers from shore and around 600
from the mouth of the Amazon it's a real
challenge to dive in conditions that no
one knows no one has ever dived here
before we have to go through a really
thick layer of sediment from the Amazon
mouth this layer is about 20 meters deep
and after that it's pitch black until
the bottom it is a deep and complex dive
careful preparation and double-checking
of equipment is essential
so there they go and they'll be heading
down to a depth of 110 meters which is
so deep they'll only have 15 minutes on
the seabed and in that time they've got
to collect samples and send them back up
to the surface and then they have to
stay in the water submerge for three
hours to decompress they drop down and
down into almost complete darkness the
scene lit by their dive lights at the
bottom they have to work fast collecting
biological samples other divers scan the
reef and film it for review revealing a
rich array of biodiversity the samples
are sent up to the surface our boat
heads over to pick them up and we haul
them on board and as the divers stay
below to decompress the samples arrive
back on the Esperanza there's all manner
of life here including all types of
mollusks crustaceans sponges and
starfish are you finding 20 because this
is all deep sea saucer meanwhile back
with the divers some inquisitive
hammerhead sharks pass by the
decompression stop it's just an inquiry
sharks lose interest and head off back
on the ship it's time for a closer look
at the kind of species that exist here
it has been an extraordinary morning and
one that even the most experienced
divers have found exhilarating
we're diving where yeah nobody have ever
been it's like discovering new a new
world in an age when our oceans are
threatened by climate change overfishing
oil drilling and deep-sea mining the
scientific evidence the team gather will
help bolster the case for greater
protection of the world's seas Nick
Clark al-jazeera off the coast of French
Guiana